معنى الان وسيم الى كوبليف وجنوب اوكرانيا
اهلا بك وسيم اذا بعد تحرير خلصن نتوقف
معك عند تباين المواقف بشان كيفيه الخروج
من هذا المازق مازق الحرب والبدء بمسار
السلام
اكد اليوم ان الحان الوقت للقوات الروسيه
بان تنسحب والا فان البديل هو ان يظل
الصراع معلقا اي ان روسيا لا تنسحب من
المناطق بما يسمح لها باعاده الترتيبها
الامني والعسكري
وشني هجمات ومعارك في وقت لا طبعا نفهم ان
الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي يريد ان يستند الى
الى واقعتي خلصا وخروج والانسحاب الروسي
ك- ورقه رابحه وان يعتبرها نقطه تحول في
همم في موازين القوى على الارض بما يفتح
له همم ولو بشكل الباب نحو مفاوضات سلام
ولكن مفاوضات سلام حسب الشروط الاكرانيه
وتقدم فيه اوكرانيا نفسها على انها الطرف
الاقوى في هذه المحادثات طبعا ما اكده لنا
وسائل اعلام يوم امس في مدينه خرسا وقال
لنا ان اوكرانيا مستعده للسلام ولكن حسب
الشروط الاوكراني ولكن ايضا اكده اليوم
امام القاده قاده مجموعه العشرين حيث ااه
كشف عن خطه خارطه طريق اوكرانيه همم تتضمن
عشر شروط لاتفاق السلام بينها وبين
روسيا من بين هذه الشروط طبعا هناك مساله
الامن النووي وحمايه الحمايه النوويه
باعتبار ان هناك همم امكانيه استخدام
تلميح من قبل موسكو باستخدام همم التهديد
النووي وهناك ايضا الامن الطاقى هو الغذاء
واسترجاع الاسرى ولكن هناك شرط مهم جدا
وهو تنفيذ ميثاق الامم المتحده في ما
يتعلق
باستعاده الاراضي الاخرانيه
بالكامل من المناطق طبعا يقصده هنا
عن خروج
روسيا من الق- القرم وميناء منطقه الجمباز
ولذلك اعتبر الرئيس وزير الخارجيه على
الروسي سيرجيلاروف ان هذا الامر سرياليا
وخياليين وغير قابل للتنفيذ باعتبار ان
روسيا تعتبر هذه المنطقه همم روسيه بمفعول
نصوص قانونيه وكذلك حتى مدينه منطقه
خرسانه التي لا تزالوا في جزء منها روسيا
حاضره تعتبرها روسيه حتى الان باعتبار مثل
الاستيناد الى الاستفتاء الذي حصل قبل سته
اسابيع نعم وداد
السلطات الاوكرانيه على تطهير هذه المدينه
وازاله الغم منها لتصبح قابله للعيش
تقعدوا معك ايضا عند الشقه الانسانيه
نعم وداد هناك الكثير من الجمعيات
والمنظمات الغير الحكوميه والجمعيات
الانسانيه التي بدات تاخذ طريقها النحو
خرسه ااا وذلك منذ يوم الجمعه وطبعا ذلك
تحت اجراءات امنيه كبيره همم مرافقه من
قبل الجيش للوصول الى مدينه خرسن التي
تفتقد الى ابسط مقومات العيش الكريم مدينه
خرسن ليس فيها ماء ولا كهرباء ولا وسائل
الاتصال كما شهدنا ذلك يوم امس وكذلك حتى
يعني ابسط السبل ال ال العيش الكريم
تفتقدها همم اوكرانيا تفتقدها اخرصا وكذلك
حتى البنيه التحتيه اكد ذلك يوم اكد ذلك
يوم امس ان البنيه التحتيه الاساسيه تم
ضربها من قبل روسيا في هذه المعارك وان
العمل الكبير ينتظر السلطات المحليه همم
في مدينه في مدينه خرسن طبعا الى ذلك
يعني ت- تستانف القوه الاوكرانيه عملها من
خلال ازاله الالغام وكذلك البحث عن ادله
على جرائم حرب وهو الشغل ل خاصه السلطات
الاوكرانيه وكذلك حتى الاسره الدوليه
ونعلم ايضا ما حصل في مدينه في مدينه
بوتشا واربين بعد خروج القوات الروسيه في
همم في وقت السابق من هذه الاماكن وما
خلفته من مظاهر للتعذيب ولي من همم مقابر
جماعيه وهو ما يكون الحال في مدينه خلصن
التي استعادتها القوات الاوكرانيه
شكرا لك